هنا وسط هذه البساتين الخضراء وعلى نهر شط
العرب تقع قريه جيكور جنوبيه البصره حيث
منزل الشاعر الكبير بدر شاكر السياب
المنزل البسيط هذا كبساطه السياب في شعره
تحوله الى متحف يضم مقتنيات وصورا وثقت
حقبه مهمه في تاريخ البصره الثقافي
على يد جد كبير مرزوق السياب اللي هو جد
الشاعر يعني جد ابو الشاعر بدر شاكر
السياب وهذا الدار كما يعني موجوده بشعره
همم موجوده همم انه بيت كبير وبيغرف كثيره
من همم من الشعر الموجود عندها قصيده مال
المطفئه هي النوافذ الكتاب يعني انه بيت
بي انا نوافذ كثير يعني بيغرف كثيره
تحول المنزل الذي يبعد نحو 20 كم عن وسط
البصره الى معلم من المعالم التي يحرص
جمهور الخليج العربي زيارتها واخذ الصور
التذكاريه هناك ومن ثم لاكمال توفيق هذه
الزياره هنا عند تمثال السياب على كورنيش
البصره حيث يقف شامخا مرحبا بضيوف في
بصرته
جميله للامانه
وتتبعون تتكلم من العراق العراق
الجنوبي والله احنا قاعدين نشوف اليوم
2023 الخليج كلها طبعا البصره ازر الشاعر
المعروف وهذا يتم ثالث الشاهد عندنا هنا
احنا الحمد لله نقول له الشاعر رحل عن هذه
الدنيا في 1964 وقل له انت مو غريب
والخليج كلها معك وان شاء الله لا يوجد
غرباء في الخليل
جمهور متعطش لمعرفه المزيد عن البصره
وتاريخها فتحت له نافذه واسعه من خلال هذه
البطوله التي اعادت لما شمل العراق بمحيطه
الخليجي شعبيا قبل ان يكون رياضيا من
البصره الفيحاء سامر الكبيسي العربيه